Considering all the fame and fortune and fans
who followed his work, it came as somewhat
of a shock when Joe Pesci announced in 1999
that he was retiring from acting to pursue
a music career.
Twenty years later, Pesci has come out of
retirement to act again, and we know the real
reason why.
Pesci is reuniting with several of his longtime
collaborators for his first major film role
post-retirement in a movie that's already
generating Oscar buzz.
In 2017, Deadline reported that Pesci would
re-team with his Goodfellas director Martin
Scorsese for The Irishman, which also stars
Pesci's frequent co-star Robert De Niro.
A biographical crime drama based on the book
I Heard You Paint Houses by Charles Brandt,
The Irishman focuses on the famous labor union
leader and alleged mob hitman Frank "The Irishman"
Sheeran, played in the film by De Niro.
Pesci is set to play American mafioso Russell
Bufalino, the leader of the Bufalino crime
family to whom Sheeran was believed to have
connections.
Following Sheeran in his old age as he reflects
on the crimes that defined his career in the
Mafia, The Irishman also stars Al Pacino as
Jimmy Hoffa, a fellow union leader and President
of the International Brotherhood of Teamsters
who disappeared in 1975 and was declared legally
dead in 1982.
Before his death in 2003, Sheeran claimed
that he was the man who killed his old friend
Hoffa.
After Paramount Pictures dropped the project,
Netflix acquired distribution rights to The
Irishman, which is scheduled to hit the streaming
service in late 2019.
That's around the time that The Irishman will
also see a theatrical launch to meet the requirements
for Academy Awards eligibility.
Considering the talent involved, one could
argue that coming out of retirement to star
in The Irishman was a no-brainer for Pesci.
Reuniting with Scorsese, De Niro, and Pacino
for a movie that could very well earn several
Academy Awards?
Pesci would be foolish to turn that down to
stay out of the public eye.
But that's actually what happened, at least
according to past reports.
According to Deadline, Pesci didn't immediately
jump on the chance to step back into the limelight
for The Irishman.
Pesci is said to have repeatedly turned down
the offer, with some sources stating that
he said no about 50 times.
This stubbornness could have been a combination
of a reluctance to come out of retirement
and a past bad experience with getting lined
up to play a mobster in a movie.
Pesci was reportedly promised the role of
real-life Gambino crime family capo Angelo
Ruggiero in director Kevin Connolly's Gotti,
and put on 30 pounds for the part, which he
never actually landed.
He wound up suing the producers for $3 million,
and settled out of court in 2013.
And if you think that's funny…
"I'm funny, how?
Like I'm a clown, I amuse you?
I make you laugh?
I'm here to f---in' amuse you?
What do you mean 'funny'?
Funny how?
How am I funny?"
It evidently took persistence and convincing
to get Pesci to sign on for The Irishman and
officially come out of retirement to act again,
but it sounds like the tipping point came
when Pesci got the full scope of the project
and the opportunities it could afford him.
Knowing he would reunite with Scorsese was
one thing, and learning that he'd be joined
by a glittering cast was another.
Still, we suspect that when Pesci got a taste
of the intense true-life story, he realized
how good The Irishman would be and ultimately
said yes.
It was always going to take a fantastic gig
to bring Pesci out of retirement, and the
role of Russell Bufalino in The Irishman seems
to be a winner.
See Pesci make his triumphant return to acting
when The Irishman rolls out in late 2019.
"I nailed it.
I did.
I nailed it."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.